what about the time
when we were in miami and uh you got
found on the roof of the parked suv
butt naked with your clothes neatly
folded and
like laying on the curb and you were
just dead asleep and they woke you up
and then
and did you did you try to fight those
cops
i i did i did threaten them i don't
think that okay i think i did try to
fight them because yeah they did mace me
oh oh you know i think you had a killer
police report on that one too yeah
and he said that i said i'll kick your
posterior i know i didn't say that but
they
they claim that i did but yeah i did
start a fight with them of course
the roof of that suv for my hotel room
yeah i was
i was on fire that night well i think i
mixed the wrong potions yeah i think
you and i hadn't seen each other for a
little while and we got a little carried
away oh i remember i remember it well
i remember it well and uh you know to be
clear
you were never uh a fan of cocaine you
just didn't you weren't you weren't into
it it was you know i was the one who
wanted to do cocaine all the time
but i did cocaine so much that it really
became a problem and i vowed to
to stop doing it you know i i gave up
cocaine
and and i had made it six months
without doing cocaine and then when we
were reunited in miami
for some unbeknownst reason pontius says
i've got a hankering for some booger
sugar
i don't know why i think it's cause we
were in miami right you know it just
felt right but it was so wrong
do you know where i can get good coke in
florida
yeah yeah glad you asked the the
bartender of the
at the bar in the hotel that we were
standing that provided some
yeah and that's all it took to kick me
off the wagon
i was like okay okay yeah
you know want us to know something weird
about that story so
for anyone that doesn't know um yeah i
after a night on the town i ended up
um being found by the police sleeping
naked on an suv
but i later found out that tripp
taylor's friend
um talked to him and he said he was
going home and he saw me
sleeping on an suv naked and he took my
clothes and
to take them into his um
and he was going to come back out and
get me but then when he came back out i
was gone
which some there's some shady business i
think
he was playing a joke on me and just
took my clothes because and my wall i
never saw my wallet
everything everything like everything
was gone all i had was
was my birthday what god gave me
all i have is what god gave me to get
out of that mess i i love it
in that story the problem is that that
guy pulled a
joke on me
that guy the problem was that that guy
undressed pontius
you strike me as somebody that like
blacks out drunk in someone's house and
like
wakes up in the middle of night and
pee's in the corner of their living room
thinking it's the bathroom
do you have you ever done it yeah like a
bad version of that
yeah like um i i think i was just
uh i sometimes i get in the mood to
really push things
like so but that time honestly i think i
just
drank too much and did whatever else
ended up going in my body that night and
you know and i really did think the suv
was my
was my hotel room and and um
and um so when the police arrived on the
scene you know
i was really grumpy to be woken up and
so i guess i did start a fight with them
and
and um they ended up pepper spraying me
i just remem like
man i mean you probably pepper sprayed
yourself steve
i've poured a lot of hot sauce in my
eyes even my own brand of hot sauce
which is called stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole
and it's now available on amazon
yeah give it five stars it's that good
it's available on prime but for all the
hot sauce i've poured in my eyes i've
never been
red pepper sprayed i have it's it's
awful and there are different levels of
it but
um but um yeah it stopped me
it it it stopped me dead in my tracks
and i'm really like when i'm fired up
i'm pretty hard to stop
and but um yeah it stopped me i i i
panicked i couldn't breathe i couldn't
see
um i was like i i was the like putty in
the police's hands at that point
i think i started crying well i was
crying of course i was pepper straight
in my eyes
and um so they thought i was crazy and
um
so they instead of taking me to jail
they took me to the hospital and i ended
up
like in in like the mental part of it
and like
i couldn't remember the name the name of
the hotel was some crazy spanish name
that
didn't roll off the tongue so i couldn't
remember what hotel we were at
you know and i had this weird orderly in
there and he was like nurse ratchet
and he's like i was frustrated because
because the police were
total gentlemen but like um this guy was
just like
giving me a hard time and and i was
frustrated because i couldn't remember
the name of the hotel
and he's like it looks seems like you
need a valium um
somebody like you're a little wound up
somebody needs a valium and i'm like
why do you think i got here in the first
place
[Laughter]
i mean it freaked me the guy was i i
guarantee you he was one of those
like mental ward like psychos that like
abuses people like
geez you know yeah and i so i had a gap
they
i had of course when i was brought in i
had no clothes on so they'd give me a
gown
but the gown like it was like
three sizes too small so like my butt's
totally hanging out
it was terrible so when i got back to
the hotel you know like
it when i first when i checked in the
night or the night before like they
treated me like a total gentleman they
called me mr pontius
and there was like a complimentary
bottle of champagne for me to enjoy
while i
was in the bubble bath dude it was the
nicest hotel
we were there we were there to present
an award at the
the latin vmas and we had like
palatial [ __ ] hotel suites
at this like super south beach hotel on
like
collins it was uh one of the more
obnoxious
big like gaudy hotel rooms that we'd
ever had
and pontius chose to sleep on the roof
of vanessa
yeah yeah dude